nearly all the skills that you'll need
to get ahead in a valent can be
sharpened before you even play the game
Valeria is an experience that combines
elements from many other shooters to
create something that puts a new twist
on familiar ideas fortunately by playing
the games it's inspired by you can get
ahead of the curve and sharpen your
skills before you're even recruited as
an agent valor --nt Counter Strike
global Offensive is the game that valor
--nt has the most similarities with from
the bomb planting and defusing format
and round by round weapon economy to
spray patterns and recoil control so it
makes sense that csgo would be the
perfect training ground and since it's
free-to-play these days you've got no
excuse not to use it as a virtual
stepping-stone to valor and success the
first thing I'll touch on is how you
navigate the maps as the movement that
both csgo and valor and have used some
classic mobility options that those that
haven't checked out CS may not be
familiar with the absence of a sprint ki
will be immediately noticeable to many
players out there with the speed of your
locomotion limited by whatever gun
you're holding the heavier the gun the
slower the run and in the wise words of
fps Doug you run faster with a knife
while it may be unfamiliar to sum the
movement fits the style of the game
perfectly as each move must be
considered whether you're approaching a
bomb site silently with the use of your
walkie and covering your angles or
rushing in an attempt to get an entry
frag and lock the location down how you
navigate the map is drilled into you
quickly while playing counter-strike
and will be a valuable transferable
skill when you come to play valor ins as
you go from your spawns your bomb site
you need to keep in mind all angles
you're approaching from or defending
most of this is going to come with
experience and map knowledge but games
like csgo or Rainbow six siege can teach
you about holding angles or safely
navigating avenues of fire for example
if you're on the defending side you
obviously need to know where the
attackers are coming from but also the
most advantageous angles as well as
develop the patience of holding the
angle so you can prevent their approach
similarly when it comes to attacking a
little experience on how to enter a site
goes a long way approaching from cover
and slowly peeking around an angle with
your crosshair trained on possible enemy
locations as you check inch by inch
until you get a franc or can move up
safely is a technique known as slicing
the pie and can
you can die ever so quickly in these
games it's imperative to give yourself
every advantage but while it's all well
and good learning how to get around the
map or approach an objective it's not
going to be much good if you don't know
how to hold your own against the enemy
team shooting in both CS and Vallance is
also quite different to games you may
already be experienced with the first
thing to keep in mind is that you should
not be shooting and moving movement adds
an extreme penalty to your accuracy in
both these games to the point that
running towards an objective with the
left mouse button held down is about as
useful as a chocolate teapot if you're
using a default crosshair then you'll
see it change and expand when you're
suffering a movement penalty in both
counter-strike and valor in the first
shot you fire from a rifle is nearly
always dead-on accurate if you are
stationary so your best bet when it
comes to winning one-on-one engagements
is to stop crouched aim and fire keeping
all this in mind takes some practice
though obviously another huge factor is
how hot your aim is how fast you can get
your crosshair onto a target
and your recoil control is going to be a
huge help to and there are tons of
training environments to download for
csgo via the Steam marketplace that
allow you to practice recoil tap
shooting headshots and target
acquisition these are the perfect places
for you to learn how to control each
weapon and their recoil when you fire
your weapons full auto you'll notice
there is quite a significant climb to
them after the first couple of shots
more so than most FPS games out there to
really make the most of these weapons
you're going to have to learn how to
bring those rounds back on targets using
these training arenas can give you a
visualization of where your bullets are
going by after toying around with them
in both counter-strike and valent for a
little while I noticed that some of the
main weapons have extremely similar
spray patterns so loading in one game
should help in huge ways when it comes
to hop to the next just so you can see
for yourself here are the recoil
patterns side by side for csgo is ak-47
and valor insuk Waveland weapon the
Vandal and again for the m4a1-s and the
phantom suppressed rifle now are they
exactly the same no are they similar
enough that learning how to control a
weapon in counter-strike will help you
in valor an absolutely the difference
with valor --nt is the
aiming-down-sights where the weapon will
reduce the spread you experience at the
cost of rate of fire although personally
I found it much easier to stick to the
classic way of aiming
the one thing that's fairly unique to
valor when it comes to combat however is
the weight abilities play into
engagements and while Counter Strike or
Rainbow six aren't going to allow you to
practice with special agent talents
there are some fundamentals that can
still be learned for example learning
how smokes can help obscure a line of
sight when attacking or prevent a push
when you're defending will serve you
well once you finally get your hands on
some of the valor and agent abilities
learning how to use a flashbang in csgo
or Rainbow six will also make you feel
more comfortable when it comes to using
Phoenix's curveballs
but what's available to you during each
round of combat depends on your economy
this may be the element of the game
that's most alien to players new to this
style of FPS but it plays an enormous
part of the dynamic the money you have
available to buy your weapons and
abilities at the start of each round
will depend on your performance both at
a team level and an individual level
there may be moments where you have to
buy a weapon for a broke teammate or if
you're on a losing streak do what's
called an eco round this isn't the fight
it's stealing lunch money
ballerina features a UI to help teams
coordinate together when it comes to
working around their economy but a few
hours of csgo will also drive home how
important is element of the game is and
how you can take advantage of it sure
you may have gotten all those kills last
round and now have a wallet brimming
with cash but these games are very much
a team effort so share the wealth a
little and be sure you're picking up the
fancy expensive stuff dropped by other
players at the end of each skirmish this
will no doubt help you save a few more
bucks for a rainy day and finally
remember Intel is the most valuable
thing of all in these games whether
we're talking about Valerie rainbow
succeed your counter-strike don't be
afraid to communicate with your team and
keep everyone informed getting the first
kill of the game can change the dynamic
and create an opening that you need to
tell your squad about spotting a bomb or
spike as is known in valent while
defending a site likely means or
approaching with the objective to plant
so tell your team you've found the
device so you can secure it or even
something as simple as letting your
comrades know that a certain player
favors a sniping position may allow them
to be better informed and obstruct their
vision but these and many lessons more
are best learn by playing and jumping
into csgo or siege will certainly help
you prepare for the combat to come many
times I've spoken to some of the top
performing allied agents I've been
matched with and I've asked have you
played this game much
Mikami responses no but I've played a
lot of counter-strike over the years so
if you want to get a little more
hands-on learning before you get access
to the game these are the titles will
allow you to get your action-packed
studying on before you play valent if
you think this might be of help to you
or your teammates be sure to LIKE the
video share it among your squad and if
you're hungry for more valor and then
you can check out our impressions piece
by clicking that spot in the top right
but to keep looped in for future value
and content then make sure you subscribe
to GameSpot
[Music]